14 Juli 2021
Wassermassen schießen durchs Tal die
Pegel steigen unaufhörlich erreichen
mancherorts 10 Meter lieber Gott
Autos Bäume ganze Häuser die Flut reißt
alles mit sich
ganz Familiengeschichte
im gesamten Aartal sterben 135 Menschen
vom
Kellergeschoss und im Obergeschoss ging
es dann nur noch drum zu überleben viele
dürfte es erlebte völlig aus der Bahn
man kam so lange lähmungsphase die mich
auch wirklich in die Knie gezwungen hat
und dann kam im Mai die Diagnose mit der
Depression der Schmerz sitzt immer noch
tief
Bau
hunderte Häuser sind noch immer
unbewohnbar ehemalige Hotel stehen als
Ruinen am Ufer der AH
andernorts kennt das Leben endlich
zurück wie sauber müssen die Steine sein
seit der Katastrophe kommt Moni vom
Niederrhein immer wieder an die A um zu
helfen einfach so und haut Andrea
Mausberg und mich um mit ihrer
Begeisterung und ihrem Elan zum Einbau
schwierig sein sollte dann kann man ja
immer noch was abhämmern die sind super
perfekt
einfach hinten auf den Paletten
wunderbar perfekt
was machst du wenn du keine Steine
säuberst und stapelst als Beruf als
Beruf
und habe eben in Deutschland bald Märkte
und warum machst du das warum hilfst du
so toll
die Andrea
ich finde aber es ist ein
Grundeinstellung wenn man einmal
wirklich ein bisschen denkt ganz einem
selber passiert wäre oder so und wir
sind alle keine Menschen die freiwillig
Fragen um Hilfe nee das tun wir nicht
also besonders für Frauen
schwierig also das ist ein echter
Prozess gewesen ne ähm ich habe auch
vieles verpasst in den Anfängen auch an
finanzieller Unterstützung das schaffst
du schon was schaffst du schon es sind
Menschen wie Moni die Andrea helfen
weiter zu machen oder überhaupt
anzufangen der lange war ihr das nicht
möglich
ich war lange wirklich in der
Schockstarre und habe retrospektiv das
Gefühl ich wurde auch mehr gelebt als
dass ich selber gelebt habe also ich
habe natürlich Dinge entschieden wenn
ich gefragt wurde was ist hiermit was
ist damit aber so wirklich bewusst nach
einem Plan vor und deshalb ist im
letzten Jahr auch kaum was passiert was
eigentlich mehr um die Krankheit ging
und Klinikaufenthalt und jetzt so mit
dem neuen Jahr habe ich versucht durch
zu starten weiß auch echt eine
kraftfrage ist und da kommen auch immer
wieder Tiefs
[Musik]
aber ich versuche mich jeden Tag wieder
auszupappeln in der flutnacht stieg das
Wasser rasend schnell mit ihrer Tochter
verbrachte sie bange Stunden im
Obergeschoss nicht wissen ob sie dort
wirklich sicher sind seitdem ist das
uralte Fachwerkhaus das einst ihre
Urgroßeltern gekauft hatten fast völlig
zerstört
aber gehen nein
das ist meins und deshalb möchte ich auf
jeden Fall auch wieder aufbauen ist mein
Lebensmittelpunkt
wissen wie riesig der Berg für die
Betroffenen ist kommen sie immer wieder
Michael ist eigentlich aluminiumgießer
am Bodensee er macht extra Überstunden
um hier anzupacken
ihr gebt ganz viel aber es gibt euch
auch was es gibt
man man weiß auch wie das sieht gut dass
eigentlich geht und dass man eigentlich
kein Probleme hat ja ich lebe in der WG
auf 18 Quadratmeter Bier aufmachen
auch Markus Kelter hätte es ohne die
Hilfe der freiwilligen nicht geschafft
das ist mein Elternhaus
geworden richtig hier bin ich groß
geworden
im Hof wenige Habseligkeiten der retten
konnte alles andere mitgerissen zerstört
[Musik]
wenn sie dann draußen stehen und
ja haben da eine ganze Kommode ein ganze
Sideboard mit 30 Fotoalben und das liegt
alles auf der Straße drauf sondern der
Baggerfahrer kommt mit dem Radlader und
greift rein und lässt auf eine Karre
drauf
gewesen und für uns einer was steht ins
Herz
zwei Jahre sind vergangen der Schmerz
ist immer noch frisch dazu die vielen
Rückschläge etwa als er erfuhr dass
seine Elementarversicherung bei weitem
nicht ausreicht
da habe ich dann im März eben den Anruf
von der Versicherung bekommen die dann
sagte so wir nähern uns der Schadens
Höchstsumme weil ich denke nie
Französisch
und dann ist erstmal ein ganz tiefes
Loch aufgegangen wo ich gedacht habe
zieht einer dem Boden unter den Füßen
weg
und dann ja siehst du am Ende vom
Horizont eine große Summen weiß ich
wieder da dran kommen sollst jetzt hofft
er auf staatliche Gelder den Antrag
dafür hat er gerade abgeschickt endlich
hatte er die Energie dafür
also ich hoffe jeden Tag dass ich
durchhalte dass ich das Ding hier fertig
kriege
dass mir die Kraft nicht aus geht die
Motivation nicht aus geht weil ich
einfach wieder fertig haben möchte und
vielleicht irgendwann mal Richtung
normales Leben wieder
leben möchte
denn von einem normalen Leben ist es ATA
noch weit entfernt immer wieder höre ich
nach zwei Jahren sind die Menschen hier
vor allem eins erschöpft
[Musik]
umso wichtiger sind da die kleinen
Lichtblicke dafür sorgt Angelika
urbin-wanne von der mobilen fluthilfe
der Diakonie das Haus der Gabriels
konnte zwar gerettet werden aber die
Familie ist nicht versichert wie da die
Komplettsanierung stemmen in ihrer
Verzweiflung bat Heike Gabriel die
Diakonie um Hilfe und immerhin mit der
sieht es gut aus
ich bin da guten Mutes dass wir quasi
die ganze Küche übernehmen können das
wäre Wahnsinn
wenn die Anträge genehmigt sind verteilt
die Diakonie Spendengelder bis 5000 Euro
etwa für Möbel oder im Küchen oder
wieder Aufbauhilfe bis zu 25.000 Euro
Folgeanträge möglich
Angelika Urin Wanne hilft beim Ausfüllen
wenn sich die Betroffenen überhaupt
melden also viele kommen mit diesen
digitalen Anträgen nicht zurecht
beziehungsweise
erstmal ist das Ding dass er gar nicht
wissen dass es die Hilfe überhaupt gibt
also da fängt schon an viele fühlen sich
verloren weil sie nicht wissen dass es
von der Diakonie oder anderen
Wohlfahrtsorganisationen Unterstützung
gibt eben als haushaltsbeihilfe oder
Wiederaufbauhilfe es nimmt ein Stück
weit die Angst den Berg nicht besteigen
zu können man bekommt das Gefühl
vielleicht schaffen wir es ja doch
das ist vielleicht geht es ja irgendwie
ich kann das nicht in Worte fassen das
ist
ja eine Hilfe eine Riesenhilfe obwohl es
das eigentlich nicht wirklich
beschreiben ist das viel mehr es ist
auch Kraft die es gibt
viel Kraft braucht es auch dringend
direkt gegenüber bei Ingo poppelreuther
läuft's überhaupt nicht zwar sieht sein
Haus von außen okay aus aber seit der
flutnacht ist es unbewohnbar das Wasser
stand bis zum Obergeschoss seitdem ist
wenig passiert das Nachbarhaus hingegen
längst abgerissen und wieder aufgebaut
mich freut es einerseits dass sie
weiterkommen ne aber tut genauso gut weh
damit man sieht sie wie wie weit sie
schon sind oder wie weit ich sein könnte
und bei mir ist immer noch Stillstand
weil die Wände mit Öl verseucht sind
bleibt nur der Abriss
versichert die Versicherung aber
reagiert seit zwei Jahren nicht
und ich weiß nicht machen soll
an seinem Arbeitsplatz sieht es auch
nicht besser aus poppelreuther ist
Hausmeister an der aartalschule in
Altenahr auch sie seit der Katastrophe
eine Ruine das Wasser stand hier vier
Meter hoch da unter dem Grünen und die
schwarze obere Kante ist das ist so die
Wassersäule
immerhin jetzt endlich soll die
Turnhalle abgerissen werden die Statik
ist nicht zu retten das allerdings steht
schon lange fest Verbandsbürgermeister
Dominik gieler dauert das alles viel zu
lange
ich hätte mir schon gewünscht dass man
wenn die Gutachten vorliegen und die
Gutachten sagen das ist staatlich nicht
mehr haltbar dass man dann schneller zu
dem Ergebnis kommt es wird abgerissen
und es wird wieder aufgebaut auch in den
Schulräumen passiert seit zwei Jahren
nichts unterschiedliche Fördertöpfe
wieder Aufbau vor Schulbau Richtlinie
sich stellen die mitreden wollen all das
kostet Zeit und Kraft
man will Vorankommen weil mit Mandel
machen man wird durch
Vergaberichtlinien gebremst man wird
durch Fachkräftemangel gebremst man wird
durch Entscheidungswege gebremst ich
meine das ist unstrittig dass wir hier
eine Schule haben die soll wieder in
Gang gebracht werden und
das ist aber doch komplizierter als man
sich das wünschen würde
Ingo poppelreuther wohnt nach wie vor
wie viele andere bis auf weiteres in
einem tiny-haus
hunderte dieser Notunterkünfte wurden
nach der Flut errichtet ein Leben auf 37
Quadratmetern mit dem wenigen was er
retten konnte
die Vase habe ich noch aber früher als
Junggesellen
[Musik]
die habe ich noch
Motorrad aber Motorrad ist kaputt
[Musik]
mit der Enge kommt der klar aber wann
kann er endlich sein altes Haus abreißen
und neu bauen die Warterei macht ihn
fertig
ja also hier geht langsam voran ist da
alles ein bisschen Chaos aber die Küche
wird gerade aufgebaut bei David Fuhrmann
dagegen geht es mit großen Schritten
voran die neuen Möbel stehen schon die
Küche fast fertig
jetzt wo man sieht wo es fertig wird ist
ein sehr gutes Gefühl also ist klar es
ist immer noch da ich mir viel Arbeit
kommt immer noch viel zusammen aber ich
glaube wenn man dann hier nachher
ankommt und liegt hier und Sofa mit der
Freundin und kannst einfach mal genießen
das ist schon ein gutes Gefühl danach
der langen Zeiten als zweiter
Bürgermeister von Dernau war der
Feuerwehrmann im ersten Jahr fast rund
um die Uhr im Einsatz
wird aufgefragt ja wird es wieder dass
der noch und es wird wahrscheinlich
nicht genau dasselbe dann auch aber ein
anderes aber das muss ja nicht weniger
schön sein ne aber es braucht halt alles
noch sehr viel Zeit
zeigt er mir jetzt bei einer Runde
durchs Dorf
das ist das gemeine mobil ja ja
das Gemeinde mobil geschenkt von einer
Försterin die damals zum helfen kann
überall wird gewerkelt und gebaut im Ort
selbst aber geht es David viel zu
langsam vorwärts der Dorfplatz ist jetzt
so das erste von öffentlichen Projekten
jetzt sowas unseren Ort angeht was jetzt
endlich mal wo was passiert hat auch
unheimlich gedauert muss ja es muss eine
Ausschreibung gemacht denn es muss
mehrere Angebote eingeholt werden alles
so wie immer alles sehr bürokratisch
halt nicht vereinfacht parallel wird die
Straßenbeleuchtung die ist immer noch
nicht wieder komplett im Gange in der
nach zwei Jahren muss man sich halt auch
mal vorstellen
eins ist klar von Normalität und Alter
kann nach wie vor keine Rede sein er ist
das seniorendorf
die auch noch
alle gewohnt in unseren Senioren da
haben sie wirklich richtig schönes hier
äh ein schönes Projekt ist da entstanden
14 alte Menschen leben hier haben sich
angefreundet einige möchten sogar
bleiben bewundernswert wie die Senioren
das Beste aus ihrem Provisorium machen
fast alle der 600 Häuser in Dernau waren
betroffen über 60 mussten bislang
abgerissen werden
auch traute mörke lebt im tiny House
seit gut einem Jahr
das haben sie sich aber schön gemacht
hier ja so viele Blumen ja ich liebe Flo
in der flutnacht hat sie wirklich alles
verloren in ihrer Erdgeschosswohnung und
nur überlebt weil sie sich ins
Treppenhaus flüchten konnte ich weiß es
nicht ich habe das eigentlich gut
weggesteckt auch jetzt noch von über 100
auf 37 Quadratmeter kein Problem für
traute sie fühlt sich wohl in der
Gemeinschaft mit den anderen hier auch
wenn einige schon wieder nach Hause
konnten bald aber ist es auch bei ihr
soweit war das alles neu kommt ne freut
man sich ja auch sondern 30 Jahre oder
noch länger
gehabt aber jetzt kommt ja alles klar
hatte ich alles mit Holz gehabt
Holzdecken und Küche dunkel jetzt alles
ganz zu lernen mit knapp 80 alles noch
mal neu alles anders traute mörke lässt
sich nicht unterkriegen nicht von
schwerer Krankheit nicht vom Tod ihres
Mannes und schon gar nicht von der Flut